so i'm
maury samuels and i'm director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
one of the co-hosts of this conference
with steve pitty
and it's my great pleasure uh today to
introduce our second keynote speaker
my colleague timothy snyder and i should
say that we're incredibly grateful
to tim for literally getting off a plane
i think from iceland
uh in order to come here today so thank
you
i'm going to be very brief because i
know we're running late and you all want
to hear tim
so he's the richard c levin professor of
history
at yale university and a permanent
fellow at the institute for human
sciences in vienna
he received his doctorate from the
university of oxford
in 1997 where he was a british marshall
scholar
and he joined the yale faculty in 2001.
his work is distinguished by his command
of languages he speaks five and reads
ten and by the way he integrates
multiple national contexts
into historical discussion and debate
particularly of the holocaust
among his publications are eight single
authored
award-winning books all of which have
been translated
into multiple languages and in the
interest of time
i'll just mention the last three
bloodlands
europe between hitler and stalin from
2010
black earth the holocaust is history and
warning
from 2015 and most recently
on tyranny 20 lessons from the 20th
century
2017 which has made it onto the new york
times bestseller list
bloodlands won 12 awards including the
emerson prize in the humanities
and the hana aren't prize in political
thought it has been translated
into 33 languages was named to 12 book
of the year lists and was a bestseller
in six countries
tim is also the co-editor of two books
uh wall around the west
state borders and immigration controls
in europe and north america
and stalin in europe terror war and
domination
and he collaborated with tony judd on
thinking the 20th century from 2012.
in addition to this amazing outpouring
of scholarly publishing
he has somehow found time to write for
the new york review of books foreign
affairs
the times literary supplement the nation
the new republic
as well as for the new york times the
international herald tribune the wall
street journal and other
newspapers he was the recipient of an
inaugural andrew carnegie follow
a fellowship in 2015 and received the
hovel foundation prize the same year
most recently he was named a guggenheim
fellow
he's a member of the committee on
conscience of the united states
holocaust memorial museum
is the faculty advisor for the fortune
off collection of holocaust testimonies
at yale
and sits on the advisory councils of the
evo institute for jewish research and
other organizations
the title of his keynote address today
is on tyranny
please join me in welcoming tim snyder
[Music]
thank you very much maureen most of the
lectures i've given the last six months
have been
to non-academic publics which has
convinced me all the more that space
matters and physicality matters which is
to say
if you feel like moving closer
you will in fact understand more of what
i say
and we will in fact have a better
conversation i'm going to admire the
first person who actually stands up and
moves closer
that's going to be you sir all right
thank you well done well done well done
um so i'm going to be i'm going to begin
with with with two confessions
the first of them mori has already made
for me which is that
i did indeed just come back from iceland
which means that
i i haven't heard the arguments that
you've made unless you made them in the
last 20 minutes so
i i risk saying something that you have
said
worse um i risk filling in gaps that
that aren't gaps
so all i can promise to you is is a kind
of general conceptual
argument which i hope you will find
useful as you consider
the specific claims that have been our
have been have been our topic the last
couple of days
the second confession is i'm a historian
that's the second confession so what i
have to offer
will have to will have to be limited to
the way that historian might think about
the present moment which is something
as moira was kind of suggest i've been
i've been trying
to do so let me start let me start with
iceland i'm going to take
five minutes and i'm going to work
iceland out of my system
and and at the end of it we'll all we'll
all be together i think
on on the same on the same page it is
it's very striking to spend 24 hours in
a country
which was uh which was set up by vikings
a thousand years ago
at the same time that one is trying to
teach a class about how vikings set up
another country
a thousand years ago is there anyone
here who's actually in history 263 right
now
no okay veterans no all right um
so i the the the age of the vikings is
where i begin
my east european history class as as you
will as you will all remember i'm giving
you just a moment of
what is going to seem like recreation
from your harsher subjects
as you'll remember the age of the
vikings involved scandinavians spreading
out from what's now ukraine
to what's now iceland and and even
further and it's very odd for me as i
one day to be teaching about ukraine the
next day to be in iceland
realizing that the same runes the same
languages are being used in the same
place at the same time by
by pretty much the same people that the
vikings who got to iceland and success
on their boats left those same runes on
the nippero river
um to commemorate uh vikings who died
trying to go down those those
those southern rapids it's it's really
striking to think that these these
pagans converted at about the same time
at about the year one thousand
in in iceland um from the norwegians
there was no choice
in kiev same vikings same people but
many many choices in
kiev they're actually just judaism and
islam about and christianity is visibly
divided
so the fact that the vikings in in kiev
end up being eastern christians is
is in large measure a matter of chance
it's striking to to
to contrast the cultures um that the
vikings or the post vikings the
the icelanders in the 13th and 14th
centuries could write 40 sagas
which frankly like beat the hell out of
pretty much any comparable literature in
europe it's an extraordinary
thing and then to compare that to what
are already being built
as the byzantine the eastern christian
cathedrals and monasteries
of kiev again similar starting points
but now we're branching out into very
different cultures
and to very different agricultures which
can seem like just chance or can seem
like the center of everything depending
on how you're looking
if you if you drive around iceland what
you see
are volcanic mountains which were
stripped by the human settlers and are
still largely stripped
only one percent of isi of iceland is
now forested and that's a result of
human settlement and it's
we still have not recovered eight
centuries eight centuries on
whereas those vikings who settled in
ukraine happened to find themselves
amidst black earth amid some of the most
fertile soil in the world
which is still some of the most fertile
soil in the world and so whereas
the vikings in iceland scratched out in
existence and prospered for a couple of
centuries
the vikings in in in kiev stop selling
slaves and instead started to exploit
the labor of the people around them
and built up a civilization which was
known as ruse these are the things that
i was thinking driving around iceland
yesterday and flying back to iceland
today i'm just barely scratching the
surface of this thing which is called
history but what i want to try to
suggest is that
history is a way of processing events in
the present
and it's a way which contrasts more
clearly than it might seem
with other ways that we might use the
past so while i'm in iceland i'm also
hearing of a friend
who just by chance as a child learned to
write in rooms
right because that's the kind of person
she happens to be
and has now stopped writing in runes
because she's realized that american
nazis are making
runes their favorite way of writing
right um
as i'm in iceland i'm also thinking of
the history of ancient ruse
that settlement in kiev by vikings
roughly a thousand years ago
which has become a highly racialized um
and and highly abstract uh imaginary
beginning point
of the history of of russia there are
ways of thinking about the past which
i'm going to call the politics of
eternity which seem like they have to do
with history they
they invoke they refer to points in the
past
but they're not interested in the
combinations the comparisons the
chronologies which i tried to suggest so
briefly when i was talking about iceland
a moment ago
of course there's another way of
thinking about the past um which is
native to the united states of america
and which is pretty widespread
in which i would call the the politics
of inevitability
which says that there's no particular
reason to know these details about the
past at all
since we know what the present is going
we know what the future is going to be
anyway the details the details cease to
matter
what i want to try to do in the next
half an hour or so before before we talk
is to compare these ways of thinking
about the past and suggest that i like
the word conjuncture
which which i think brendan used in last
compare the ways that these thinking
about the past arrive
arrive and arise in our conjuncture and
what they might mean for race
and what they might and what they might
mean for the way we think about
the way we think about um the way we
think about community we've come to
think about community okay
so let me say a word about the politics
of inevitability
then a word about the politics of
eternity and then at the very end i'll
say something about about this whole
tyranny business
so by the politics of inevitability i
mean a certain kind of timescape
and and this should start to sound
familiar the more that i talk about it
because many of us live in it at least
some of the time
um i would i would go so far i would go
so far as to say that
most people in this country live in it
most of the time the politics or at
least they did until november of 2016.
um the the politics of inevitability
says something like this
um time moves forward in a line or maybe
time is like a cone where things just
get better as
time moves on um the present
uh the present is is is worse than the
future than is better than the past
we we know which way things are going
um and and it's the future really which
confirms meaning
on confers me on the present right so if
there's some kind of crisis in the
present that's fine because we know that
it's the birth pangs of something or
other
this way of seeing the the the future
the present the past this way of
experiencing time
is something that unites systems that
might seem to be different it's true for
example of both leninism
and um what was called neoliberalism now
i'm going to promise only to use the
word neoliberalism
once in this presentation which i think
is a rule that we should all follow okay
so i've now used the word neoliberalism
once that's my one time
if i use it again you could you should
you can feel free to boo in his
so um so what what what leninism would
say would be something like this
or just marxism that nature lisa
technology leads to conflict
which leads to revolution which leads to
some good thing right
neoliberalism might say something like
nature lisa technology which leads to
competition which leads to technical
solutions which leads to some
to some good thing right the stripped
down american version would be
nature means markets means democracy
means means we're all happy
so that's what that's what the politics
of inevitability
looks like what i want to suggest is
that we were living in that
um we were living in that many of us uh
until about 2000 until about 2016.
now um there there is there
is of course okay there's also a
european version which i'm going to talk
about a little bit later but
the there's a european version which is
really which is really interesting which
is which is just as wrong
um and how much i make fun of whom
depends on which side of the atlantic i
i am so what's wrong what's wrong with
the american version we know what's
wrong with the american version there's
no point particularly dwelling on it
um we know that there's a contradiction
in believing that markets automatically
generate democracy we just experimented
that by allowing endless money into
politics in 2006 right
um we we know that the shock of the
financial crisis of 2008 had
rather significant consequences and
we're aware i'm sure you've been
discussing in various ways and i'm going
to return to it
the way that the resulting inequality
affects democracy let me let me state
let me pause for just a minute on the
european version
so there's there's a there's the
american politics of inequality there's
a politics of inevitability there's also
a european version which is slightly
you know as european things are it's
slightly more subtle so it's going to
take me it's getting
about 15 more seconds to explain it the
the the history of europe the story of
the history of europe
um in in the 19th and 20th centuries the
main drama history of the europe is the
transition from
from empire to integration okay that's
history in the sense of what actually
happened now is what i'm talking about
the transition from
empire to integration that's the main
story of what actually happened
the the accompany myth or fairy tale
is the story of the nation-state the
nation-state is there
so that we don't see what actually
happened which is the big transition
from empire to to integration
the story that europeans tell which is
cool and appealing and makes americans
feel guilty
is that there was there was something
called the second world war
europeans learned from the second world
war that war is bad
europeans are smarter than americans
because americans haven't learned that
yet
right that and and therefore european
union
that's the story now the only thing the
only thing wrong with that story is
everything
um europeans did not learn from the
second world war that war was a bad
thing
european if that so if think about that
proposition just for a second like we've
heard it so many times that it's like
second nature but
it's not it there's no all the evidence
is it is the other way
the europeans who suffered most from the
second world war were in order
the jews the biela russians the
ukrainians uh the polls and the russians
please try to convince me that those
people learned from the second world war
that war was a bad thing
right uh you just you cannot construct
um from a history of political theory in
those countries
the conclusion that pacifism arose right
in in jewish polish ukrainian russian
and beyond russian political thought
after the second world war
um what actually happened is more subtle
and more interesting
and it breaks the line between european
and global history and therefore has
some chance of being true
and that is this what actually happened
is that
europeans learned from losing colonial
wars
that maybe wars were a bad thing so what
the second world war
is is the transposition of colonial war
inside europe the main action in the
second world war in europe
is the german invasion of the soviet
union which is a colonial war
the point of the german invasion of the
soviet union is to destroy the soviet
union
and to control the aforementioned black
earth
of ukraine that is the colonial aim and
it is the central aim of
the german war on the eastern front
which is the front of the war that
matters
right and since the germans the ones who
start the war it's their aims that
matter
so the german invasion of soviet the
soviet union 1941
is the last major european colonial
offensive it just so happens
to take place inside europe which we
find confusing or some of us at least
find confusing
the germans you know jump to 1945 you'll
know how this ends
they lose the war now we tend to then we
tend to then bracket that into some kind
of special experience of a second world
war but it's not
that is in fact the first major european
defeat
in a colonial war right and it is
followed by many
others the reasons why germans begin the
process of european integration
first is that they are first to lose and
in an incontrovertible
and unappealable fashion a colonial war
so they then begin a process of
integration
with their west european neighbors which
is then taken up by who
by other european powers who are busy
losing colonial wars
right the the dutch the dutch the french
the british the the portuguese the
spanish
what happens is that european powers
maritime empires
lose their maritime empires and as they
lose their maritime empires
they find a soft landing in europe
the story that they tell themselves and
most importantly and tellingly and
fatally their children
is that there was a nation the whole
time
the english the british whatever the
french the portuguese the spanish
and that nation chose chose europe
that's the fatal mistake
and that's the politics of inevitability
because it suggests that there was a
nation the whole time
which it wasn't and it also suggests
that there was a nation state at some
point in this country's history
now that there was a nation state at
some point in the history
of europe is an axiom which is so
deeply felt and believed that and i've
tried this a number of times
you can shock pretty much any i'm going
to use the word elite once now you can
shock pretty much any elite european
audience at any such in any circumstance
by claiming that there was no european
nation state in the modern period
but then as soon as and the interesting
thing is as soon as they think about it
for 15 seconds
they tend to agree right but the fact is
that it's never
called into question the story that
actually takes place is
empires break up and join the
integration process but the story that's
told in school is
there was a nation the whole time there
was a nation state at some point and the
nation state made a decision
but here's the thing the nation state
never existed and this is where um
let's call it populism this is where
populism i like i call it sado populism
but i'll go into why later this is
this is where populism sees its weakness
and makes its move
because everybody thinks there was a
nation state in the past
which means that populists can say why
don't we just go back to that nation
state
right why don't and and no one literally
no one replies
because that never existed you can't go
back to it
so in this way and this is the arc of an
argument a large organ i'm trying to
make
the politics of inevitability the sense
that things always go on that are
heading towards some kind of better
future
always opens the way to the politics of
eternity it always always has there's
always that there's always um
there's always a gap in the shield
there's always an achilles there's
always an achilles heel
no um okay think about this
my glasses in there so um the the
the the particular way um and i'm sure
you all have noticed this and perhaps
talk about it the particular way that
the european
politics of inevitability works is that
it seeks after
a nostalgia for for the 1930s it's the
1930s where one imagines
that there once was a european nation
state um in a fuzzy way of course
and and i think it's worth noting that
1930s have become a kind of
universal object of nostalgia okay this
brings me to the politics of eternity
now let me talk in a kind of abstract
way about the relationship between the
politics of inevitability
the idea that everything is going to go
well that we know the rules of history
that history is over because we know
what's going to come
the relationship with that and the
politics of eternity
the timescape of the politics of
eternity is different
it's about repetition it's about cycles
right it's about things that happen over
and over and over again
and if you look hard there's actually
only one thing
that ever happens over and over again
and the one thing that happens over and
over again
is that um the perverted aggressive
outsider tries to penetrate the
ineffable virtue of us
and that happens over and over and over
again and
it's like the politics of inevitability
that in that you don't have to know the
details
right you don't actually have to have
any historical facts to recognize that
pattern
that once you know that that's the
pattern that those are the cycles
it's pretty easy to interpret whatever
anyone might happen to say
in in terms of that in terms of that
pattern so history is history is a kind
of permanent
it's a kind of permanent siege now the
politics of eternity is also like the
politics of inevitability in that
the present doesn't have any meaning on
its own
right and this for me is like the really
interesting let's not call it a paradox
because that word is almost never truly
applied we've always called irony
um this is the really interesting irony
when we say history we think
we think okay what we think the past
irrelevant you know wins dinner
but but in fact it's only history
that takes the present seriously other
ways of thinking about the past are
there to abolish
the present so if you're if you believe
in the politics of eternity
if you believe that what happens in the
present has meaning with respect to some
coming future
then the present doesn't really exist if
you believe in the politics of eternity
if you believe the same thing is
happening over and over again
then again the present the present
doesn't really exist
um likewise the politics of
inevitability and the politics of
eternity
do something similar do something
similar to the idea of reform
if you believe you know if you believe
in the magic of markets or whatever
class conflict if you believe in some
mechanism of the politics of
inevitability
you don't really need to care about
reform right you don't have to
contemplate seriously what reform would
entail
because better things are more or less
going to come regardless of what you do
likewise if you believe in the politics
of eternity if you believe that history
is a cycle
that the nation is constantly under
siege reform becomes unthinkable
because how can you talk about reform
when the enemy is constantly
at the gate and if you take the same
argument one step further you see that
both of these ways of thinking
do the same thing to the idea an idea an
important idea whereas he
with which mr seymour closed the idea of
responsibility
because if we know the way things are
going to turn out then
you don't have to bear responsibility
likewise if you know
the the cycle of history and you're in
the middle of it
you don't have to bear responsibility
and you know while while we're on the
subject
both of them do away with morality
because
if you know the good thing already and
the good thing is in the future
then whatever brings about whatever
hastens that good
alternative is good the politics of the
attorney works the same way
you already know the bad thing the bad
thing is the enemy which is eternally
encircling and who is always coming back
and thereby by default the definition of
good is defending yourself and the
community against the enemy
so there's no need to think about to
think about what's good so
these my my point here is that these
these forms of thinking about time
inevitability eternity
right you know let's let's say if you
want capitalism and socialism over here
and uh populism in the modern sense
right
i don't mean populism and fascism over
here they seem to be different
and they are okay they are they are of
course different but in
one in these particular respects and the
way they handle time
there there's some straight time
responsibility morality
there are some striking similarities and
there
there are more than similarities there's
the particular ways
in which one of them opens the way to
the other one
which is what i which is what i see and
feel in our conjuncture
now i mean what i see and feel is the
politics of inevitability giving way
to the politics of eternity the politics
of inevitability weakening
fischer's opening and the politics of
eternity emerging
and and strengthening a lot of the
events
that we observe and chronicle um and
pace and pay attention to i think could
be
could be could be understood in in these
terms let me let me give this a shot
with russia okay so um let me give this
a shot with russia
now i'm the last person who would say
that the particularities
of the rise of the russian right or its
influence in the united states
are of no interest um anton shkapletsov
works on these things
they're fascinating i've learned from
him but what i want to try to suggest is
that
there's a pattern beneath these details
and that the reason why russia
is so interesting or so important is
that russia is a pioneer
in passing from the politics of
inevitability to the politics of
eternity
what is world historically unique about
contemporary russia is that it has made
it which means its population its
leaders the people have the wealth and
people who don't
have made this transition from
inevitability to eternity twice in one
lifetime
twice in one lifetime in the 1970s when
communism in russia ceased to be about
the future
and started to become about the past
which is a long story but the 1970s
brezhnev says
so the whole story of communism right is
that there's a future right i mean this
is the heartening story of communism
there's a future of justice where you
can imagine man is going to return to
his nature
in the 1970s brezhnev says no
actually i mean you know you can't quote
jack nicholson because the movie hasn't
come out yet but brezhnev basically says
this is as good as it gets um he calls
the
the radical inequality um and the
crankiness of
1970s soviet socialism really existing
socialism so he basically abolishes the
future
in communism and instead and this is
clever and it's important
um for the future instead he replaces
that with a vision
with a nostalgic vision of the second
world war right now why is that
important
because it's a shift from the politics
of inevitability to the politics
of eternity and it means that the west
is the enemy for a different reason
the west is no longer a temporary enemy
which will be our friend in the future
after the revolution
the west is now a permanent enemy
because the west is always attacking
russia like it did in 1941.
so that's the version of communism with
which the present elite and population
i said elite twice okay that which was
the present leadership and population of
russia
was educated i mean for me the 1970s the
crucial decade
that's time number one right and that's
really interesting i mean just to know
that putin and lukashenko
came through that kind of education
where you could be both leninist
and nostalgic is i think very important
but
in addition to that russians passed
through
a moment of the 1990s when the politics
of inevitability failed a second time
which was the failure of the capitalist
version right because it did not turn
out i'm making a short story short
it did not turn out that um that
completely liberated markets
brought about beautiful democratic
institutions and happiness for everyone
right
that did not happen in russia in in the
1990s and so
both versions of the politics of
inevitability
for simplification the communist one in
the capitalist one failed
in rapid succession in in the mature
lifetime
of the same generation the one that's
now the one that's now in power
and this shift from
um inevitability to eternity also has a
logic
which one can perhaps see is better in
russia or maybe this way we can see it
better in ourselves if we first look at
russia
at least if we're american because i
mean as americans cannot look at
themselves
that's a different story but we have to
look somewhere else to see ourselves so
the interesting thing about russia is
that you can see a mechanism
by which the politics of inevitability
get to it gives away the politics of
eternity in russia
which is precisely which is precisely
radical economic inequality
it's not when i say that the capitalist
politics of inevitability fails
that's really abstract right when i say
that markets don't lead to democracy we
all know that that's the case
you know we know that the elections in
russia are ritualized and faked and so
on
but there's something deeper here which
is the way people feel about it
when people feel that they're doing
worse off or that only a few people are
doing much better than they are
stories of progress no longer make sense
that happens in russia
just a tiny bit before it happens in the
united states
and that's why you know russia makes
this turn
to the politics of eternity slightly
before
we do right which which i think you have
to have
in the background before you start
talking about russia
and the united states happy as i am to
talk about that
now russia is also the pioneer
in extracting ideologies
from the 1930s and bringing them back to
us
other people fool around in this steve
bannon fools around this
the poles fall around in this the
hungarians fool around with this farage
fools around with this
making the pen pulls around with this
but the ones who have done it really
seriously
are the russian leadership vladimir
putin is the only head of state to my
knowledge in the 21st century
who has actually taken a major fascist
thinker
of the 1930s and ensconced him as the
state philosopher
the man's name is yvonne eileen and
ivanolin is is an eternity politician
par par excellence okay so that brings
us
that brings us to to russia now
it's easy and cool and fun to talk about
how
um russia elected donald trump which
they did right i mean the infowar
the infowar and the cyber war which they
were just
practicing on ukraine in 2014 when
nobody was paying any attention
was then brought to a much higher level
of perfection by the time they were
working it out on us in 2016.
unfortunately for us we had no sense
that the story of russian ukraine was
about us
it was about exotic people who maybe
spoke exotic languages but we weren't
sure which
right but we knew it had something to do
with runes um
because we know this is really important
because we saw
the the because we saw you praying
entirely in terms of culture
right and we saw it as a distant exotic
culture if you're inside the politics
of inevitability you see these weird
conflicts as a result of cultural
backwardness
and you ask yourself questions like oh
what language do they speak are there
two ukraines or they're one ukraine it
must be all about their backward
culture and that cyrillic or whatever it
is that they use those runes
glagolitic we're not sure um so we
nobody in america
has a first approximation i'll say
nobody nobody in america treated the
events of ukraine in 2014 as having
anything to do with american politics
but they turned out to have everything
to do with american politics that though
you know that that's half the story
half the story is is the techniques that
russia had already developed
inside russia to manage inequality which
would then apply to the us
but the other half of the story is our
is our vulnerability
the really critical thing the really
critical thing about the united states
is the way that we become like russia
right
the reason why russian politics of
eternity
work in the united states is not just
that they're smarter than we are which
they are
um they have more experience with the
politics of eternity which they do
that they have their cool fascist
hegelian philosophers you know which
they do
that's all interesting but the important
thing
is that our society that's my american
art
our society is coming to look like
russian society in terms of the
disposition of wealth
and therefore the reasons why people
think that
each that that politics and this goes
back to the last panel that politics is
nothing more than a cycle of things
happen over and over again
is that they actually do not have the
experience of social advance and they
don't believe their children are going
to have it other either
and when you don't have the experience
of social advance the story of the
politics of inevitability
of progress ceases to resonate ceases to
make sense
and so russian propaganda may have been
very clever and it was
um and they may have targeted very well
which they did but there was a big
fat rich target in the united states and
the reason it was so big and rich and
fat was because the united states looks
more and more like like like like russia
okay so in that way you know our
timescape
was bending right the politics
inevitability was bending
it was falling down it was starting to
circle itself right gravity makes things
orbit
the gravity of poverty the gravity of
misery it makes things orbit we fall we
fall into a cycle right as the russians
have fallen into a cycle the gravity of
poverty
the gravity the gravity of misery okay
then
europe so how does this apply to europe
what's the politics of eternity in
europe
in in in practice it it's it's also the
case
that um russia has something to do with
european
disintegration but it's the same story
they know what they're doing in their
applying techniques but the reason why
the techniques work
is that the soft spot is real in the
case of europe
um the russians support the scottish
referendum for independence
they support brexit although even they
are surprised when that one turns out
um they they support the far right in
germany they fund marine le pen
nacional they support elements of the
extreme right as well as the extreme
right left pretty much pretty much
everywhere they practice certain kinds
of
of metapolitics giving space to radical
figures in in
in their press and they project a
certain kind of idea of
europe um where europe is at where their
version of europe is all about
innocence um innocence that russia is
innocent for example russia is innocent
of homosexuality which is not a factual
claim of course
but russia's innocent since 2013 russia
has been
um projecting a eurasian ideal
according to which russia is the center
of a kind of innocent european
civilization
and europe is the center of an
aggressive european civilization
and the reason why this works in russia
is that it
it's it's is the notion that we the
innocent ones are under attack
the reason why it works is the politics
of inevitability is if you can't reform
the state
because the people who engineered the
radical inequality are the same people
who control the state
right and that makes reform not only
impossible but literally unthinkable
then you have to change the conversation
of politics from from interests or
social advance
to to virtue and enmity and once you
have done that
it can't just be domestic policy it has
to be foreign policy as well so russia
really is interested and this makes
perfect sense by the way
in the from their point of view in this
integration of the european
union um now the the way though
that that that russian policy can apply
to europe or have some traction in
europe again has to do with the soft
spot
and i think i've already explained why
um if
if you're thinking about i mean there
are people who know much more about this
than me but if you're thinking about
brexit
like brexit is actually not a concept
right
like there's a there's not there i there
there will not be brexit
why will not be brexit you ask because
there will either not be an exit there
won't be britain
right i mean the whole the whole notion
of a british exit i think is almost
unthinkable
either they won't go at all which is my
personal opinion but if they do go they
will very quickly not be britain
now why does that does that sound
surprising the reason why i don't think
they'll be a britain is that there's
never been a britain so why should there
ever be a britain
no why should there ever be why should
there be a britain there has never been
a britain
there was a british empire for a really
long time
and then since the early 70s there has
been the participation of britain
in a larger european process of
integration but what there has never
been is a britain so why should there be
right and there's even less reason to
think that there should be one since the
architects of brexit are not thinking
about this in the radical conceptual
terms
that they would have to what they're
thinking is we just have to sort out
some technical details with the european
union and then there will be britain but
there has never been a britain so why
should there be a britain
right i do not believe there will i do
not believe they'll be read anyway
the whole idea of brexit contains two
categories which are not nearly as solid
as they seem to be right
this is all just another way of making
the same point i was trying to make
before
the soft spot the one that populists
modern populist contemporary politics
populists exploit in domestic politics
is the common belief that there was a
nation state in the past
when there wasn't right um and then the
russians in supporting
these populists are just fixing onto a
soft spot just like they fix onto a soft
spot
in in the united states there are
domestic sources the politics of
eternity
in the west and then there's a country
russia which just happens to be further
along in the politics of eternity
much more comfortable in it and has the
technical means to
to export it so i think that's where we
are which brings me to
what i want to say about history and and
and tyranny
now there are a lot of things that
historians say about all this one of
them is that the 1930s were not good
right um so no no i mean it is isn't it
interesting
how much nostalgia there is for the
1930s if we just stop
explicit or implicit i mean the idea
that our presidential
motto is america first is a striking
thing
right america first means the united
states and nazis have more in common
with each other than they
then they have differences and the
americans the nazis should be on one
side of a great walled system in which
the brown and black people are on the
other side
that's what lindbergh says and you can
hear you know lindbergh
echoed in i guess bannon wrote it but in
the inaugural address
it's striking that um that france and
britain
that many people in france and britain
are thinking of an implicit 1930s when
they imagine that there was a nation
state before the complications of the
second world war
it never happened of course but but it's
there it is striking that russia has
actually rehabilitated
one of the most i think he's interesting
i mean real philosophers i think
disagree but
um has has rehabilitated one of the more
interesting fascist thinkers of the
1930s i mean rehabilitate in the sense
of
dug up the body from switzerland and
brought it back right
taken the archives from michigan state
and brought them back
citing him in all the major addresses
sending copies of his books to every
bureaucrat in the administration as a
christmas present
recommending him to school children and
so on and so on and so on it is very
striking how the 1930s have come back
right which is a whole different subject
like we've lost the personal memory of
it
and also notice there isn't that much
history of it there's a lot of history
in the second world war of the holocaust
but how many like you you'll you'll
correct me but how many books
did you read which actually pick out the
1930s right
the 1930s that that particular decade
okay but
so historian can say the 1930s were bad
i was my career saying the 1930s were
bad i'm going to stop doing it now
and what instead i'm going to try to do
is develop a couple of closing thoughts
about how history can get us
out of this so when i said history can
create time
what do i mean one thing i meant is that
history can relativize
other forms of looking at the world so a
historian looking at this politics of
inevitability politics of eternity thing
can can you know make clever arguments
like i've tried to make
but historian can also say look this
politics between the politics
inevitability thing
is a historical development and one that
we have seen before
the first globalization of the late 19th
century also generated a politics of
inevitability
in the form of liberalism and socialism
it also then generated the politics of
eternity
in the form of fascism and national
socialism
we have seen exactly this dialectic
before
which is bracing because it means we
know where it can go
right it can go to two world wars and a
great depression it can go to genocide
and holocaust we know that
but it's also embracing a different
sense that it gives us a place to stand
that history is the thing which allows
us to take distance on these ideas and
say
these are distance in our these are
ideas in our own moment but
they're not ideas which we have to hold
that we can see them as ideas and
therefore
the moment we see them as ideas we may
be able to take some some action
now um what what
what what how what would action
consistent well it begins i think
with with recognizing patterns if you
can see the time skates themselves you
don't have to use you know my words
or even accept these concepts but if you
can see the concepts the timescapes
themselves
if you can see them right as opposed to
living within them
then you're beginning to empower
yourself if you're inside the politics
of inevitability
the danger is that you personally shift
to the politics of eternity right
which happens in a couple of ways the
first way is that
you face dramatic you stupefying
disempowering inequality
and a story of progress no longer makes
sense and you fall into a different kind
of story one of
one of cycles but it can also happen if
you're shocked i mean this very
seriously now
what happened to a lot of americans in
2016 was that they were shocked
and they went from saying everything's
going to be fine to everything's going
to be disastrous and either way
as citizens there was no particular
reason to exercise
agency um you know talking about this
book at harvard i'm going to say harvard
could it could have been yale talk about
the look at harvard to a bunch of
undergraduates
i said you guys you know thought in
october
that everything was going to be great
and therefore you could go work
on wall street and now you think
everything's going to be terrible
and therefore you can go work on wall
street right
and they all laughed and nodded and
that's what i'm talking about
that you can that's the other way that
you slip right that you one
personally slips this shift is not an
abstract slip
shift slip people slip and the question
is that you how
how you stop yourself from slipping and
one of the ways is to recognize these
patterns the big ones and the small ones
i won't belabor all the ways
that 2016 was reminiscent of the 1930s
but if one has these examples in mind
one can see them one can catch them and
then one can
one can one can catch one can catch
oneself
okay which which brings me to the which
brings me to on tyranny which is this
little political pamphlet which you know
i didn't want to talk too much about but
i'm going to conclude i'm going to close
just by talking about the very first
lesson so the book on tyranny
this very lo this very brief book which
you could have read while i was talking
um in fact that has happened in fact i
think i see someone in this room who has
done that to me before
um no it's a very brief book it's a very
short book it's not it's not a history
book it's a pamphlet
it's a pamphlet it's a normative book
it's a pamphlet the very first lesson in
this book
is is don't obey in advance
do not obey advance why is that the
first lesson it's the first lesson
because it's one of the few things that
historians of the 1930s and germany
actually agree about
so we don't in fact agree about it's
that's not even a secret that we don't
agree about very much
but historians of the holocaust disagree
about an awful lot
but one of the very few things around
which there is earnest agreement
is that in the 1930s especially in 1933
in the first weeks of months after
hitler came to power in february 1933
it mattered a great deal that he
received certain forms of consent
not necessarily marching or voting but
forms of consent like
looking away not removing swastikas from
walls
not speaking out right waiting for
the general mood and reacting to the
general mood
that turns out to be much much more
important than very smart people
understood in 1933. the converse of that
is that little gestures provided that
they're made at the beginning of the
transition
have an awful lot of political way one
way to think about this is morally
that if you are that person that acts at
the beginning then you remain the person
who acts
at the beginning if you make an excuse
not to do something at the beginning
then you become the person who didn't do
something at the beginning
and one already sees in american public
life the intellectuals and the
politicians who now
nine months in are writing the op-eds
which explain why they didn't do
anything
at the beginning right that's already
present in american public life
politically actions taken at the
beginning are magnified
the long the chant it is actually it
turns out
it it in most situations it's not that
difficult
to prevent a regime change provided that
action is taken at the very very
beginning the time that goes by makes
makes non-violent action
which is the kind that i assume most of
us hope will prevail makes non-violent
action
less likely to succeed at the beginning
it has a very serious chance
but the more time goes by the harder it
becomes to practice
and the less likely it is to succeed so
for those reasons the very first
lesson of the book is is donald vein
advance it's also the first lesson
because
if you can follow that one then you'll
be able to follow a lot of the other
ones
if you can't follow that one for the
moral and political reasons that i
already mentioned
then the other ones all all cease to be
irrelevant but the reason why i'm quote
i'm closing with it
is that donald obay in advance advances
about creating time in the sense about
creating
moral choice and a sense of moral
responsibility
donald vein advance is about not
shifting from
one form from inevitability to eternity
from from progress to doom
don't obey advance is about seeing
yourself in a historical moment and and
and seeing oneself in a historical
moment is the same thing as seeing how
the historical moment can be changed
by by oneself and it's in that way that
i really do
honestly sincerely and completely
earnestly believe that
history creates time
um it creates the time the moment of
time the moment of seeing
that we need in order to be able to act
that's what i wanted to say
thank you very much for your patience
thank you especially for
you patience with iceland i appreciate
that especially
[Music]
you